what did the right eye say to the left
eye
between you and me there's something
that smells
the led light of this smartphone blinks
every time it gets a notification
it's designed and programmed in that way
but
ever wondered why do we blink our eyes
and that too
so often let's find out
[Music]
tell me is it possible to keep our eyes
open for a long time
no i don't think so after a few seconds
we give up
why our eyes are always in direct
contact with our surroundings
so they tend to dry up quickly resulting
in irritation
and to overcome this irritation we blink
but what happens when we blink our
eyelids spread a watery substance
all over the eyes this watery substance
helps in moisturizing
and in getting rid of dirt and foreign
particles
also it aids us to see things properly
[Music]
let me tell you a fact here our eyes
blink for an average of 15 to 20 times
per
minute and each blink corresponds to one
tenth of a second
but if we blink these many times then
why don't we experience a visual
blackout
well here our brain does the trick we
almost do
every task when our brain sends signals
to do so
beat from moving our hands to running
and so on
the signals are sent consciously that
means
we're asking our brain to do the tasks
but
what miracle happens in the case of our
eyes
let's play a game to understand it ready
try blinking your eyes now what did you
notice
did you experience any visual blackout
yes because you're deliberately blinking
your eyes
and you're asking your brain to do so
that's
conscious effort but wait do you
constantly think about blinking for an
entire day no right our brain
automatically does some tasks without
being asked for
and the blinking activity is one among
them
to be precise it happens without our
conscious effort
and that's the reason that even though
there are many visual blackouts
we fail to notice them and thus we see
the uninterrupted world flawlessly
can you think of any other activity that
has carried out automatically
that's correct breathing is one good
example
it happens automatically or to be
precise it happens
involuntarily in short
all involuntary activities happen
without our conscious effort
did you know that babies generally blink
lesser than adults
as we grow up the frequency of our
blinking increases
why is there this difference what
happens to our blinking pattern as we
grow
this is your q box to explore let us
know your interesting answers
in the comment section below and do
subscribe
to our channel to be part of our massive
learning community
remain curious